you know a democrat argument is bad when
they can't get even nbc's chuck todd to
go along with it but that is exactly how
far into the realm of the absurd kamala
harris is taking the white house line on
immigration final topic here since uh
we're here in texas i want to ask you
about the border
would you call the border secure
i think that there is no question that
we have to do what the president and i
asked congress to do is the first
request we made
pass
a
bill
to create a pathway to citizenship the
border is secure but we also have a
broken immigration system in particular
over the last four years before we came
in and it needs to be fixed we're gonna
have two million people cross this
border for the first time ever you're
confident this border's secure
we have
a secure border
and that that is a priority for any
nation including ours in our
administration
but there are still a lot of problems
that we are trying to fix
you can hear the desperation in chuck
todd's voice you can hear the annoyance
because he wants to believe her
he wants to go along with it he's saying
he's saying kamala kamala come on i want
to support the team
it's two million people kamala come on
seriously you got to give me something
to work with kamala
and then commentless defense
she actually has a point
obviously the border is not closed
obviously the law is not being followed
or enforced but the border is largely
secure
the government does by and large know
who is crossing the border
government's even arresting a lot of
them
and then the government is letting them
go
in some cases the government is flying
them into red states and communities all
around the country the problem is not
that the biden administration does not
have control over the border
the problem is that
the biden administration is using the
control it has over the border to ignore
the law and flood the country with
foreigners because biden thinks it will
give democrats a permanent governing
majority
it would be bad enough if the millions
of foreigners entering our country
illegally were just a case of gross
government incompetence but the reality
is worse
the ongoing crisis
has been intentional from the very
beginning i'm michael knowles is the
michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from steven zerbel
who says i have found that democrat
accusations are just a deep sense of
guilt for what they themselves have
already done a lot of truth to that when
the democrats get really upset they say
you you're denying the election results
we hear this from who stacy abrams
hillary clinton al gore all the people
who have denied it's true their
accusations are largely confessions they
just think that the rules should not
apply to them
and practically speaking the rules
usually don't apply to them because
there is a two-tier system of justice in
america you know where you're not going
to find two tiers
rockauto.com you're going to find the
same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers right now head on over
to rockauto.com write knowles in their
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you okay you you go to
rock auto to get the brakes the shocks
the carpet the wipers the headlights the
mirrors the mufflers the lug nuts any
other part that you need these guys have
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years
and most importantly they've been with
my show pretty much since the beginning
thing i love about rockauto.com is it's
extremely simple i'm not the handiest
guy in the world even i can use the
website it is so easy to navigate if
there aren't two price tiers okay for
pros and do-it-yourselfers there aren't
all these stupid kind of promos you
gotta log in at this time on tuesday
afternoon and that's when it'll be 20
off now it's always reliably low prices
and they just know what they're doing
okay i told you i had a pal he he made
the mistake he went to the brick and
mortar auto parts store wanted to get a
part they wanted 400 bucks for it he
goes on rockauto.com to their super easy
to navigate catalog right on his phone
and the part was 150 bucks okay don't
make the same mistake my friend did make
just go straight to rockauto.com and
then write noels in there how did you
hear about his box so they know that we
sent you
the democrats have been bragging for 20
years about how mass migration mostly
from latin america is going to give them
a permanent electoral majority they have
written academic political science
papers about this they have run op-eds
about this they have campaigned on this
okay this is not some wild kooky crazy
conspiracy theory this is explicitly
what they have set out to do there is
just one wrinkle here with that problem
or with it with that strategy the
strategy by and large has worked
hispanic immigrants and their children
and their grandchildren
are much more likely to vote for
democrats than most groups who were born
in america
there is a wrinkle though which is that
over the last few years democrats have
moved
significantly into the republican camp
probably still not enough to make mass
migration worthwhile for republicans
but they have moved
the the hispanics who are coming to
america
the ones who have been here for
generations
are voting for republicans in much
larger numbers than the dems ever
counted on and how are the dems
explaining this well they say this is
simply because
they are being tricked
by misinformation that's the line
most
cnn and msnbc viewers according to a new
poll that just came out by wpa
intelligence
believe that hispanics are moving to the
right
because of misinformation
it's more than half
of the people who consume legacy media
outlets believe that survey was
conducted at the end of august they
asked a thousand participants why they
think that's happening 57 of msnbc
viewers said it's the spread of
disinformation 54 of cnn viewers said
the same thing
and and then another 16 of msnbc
respondents and a full fifth of cnn
respondents said that it's because
hispanics have internalized racism
and they they just have a desire to fit
into white society direct quote that's
what's causing them
to to
lean republican
now
the reason they're saying this is
because it can never be
that hispanics are
looking at the information and coming to
their own conclusions and saying no
based on my faculties of reason and the
information that i'm getting i think
it's better for me to vote for
republicans than democrats it can't be
that
because the democrats always have to win
and they especially always have to win
with racial minority groups
so it just any time that the republicans
do well with those groups it has to be
illegitimate
this is how the democrats can say with a
straight face that we can never doubt
the results of any election and also
stacey abrams one in 2018 and also
hillary won in 2016. the way they can
say that with a straight face is that
any time the democrats win the election
is legitimate any time the democrats
lose the election
is not legitimate by virtue of the
democrats winning or losing
because that when they talk about our
democracy all they mean is the victory
of liberalism
so that's that's what decides it i know
it's it's backwards if you think about
it in just what the words mean but
that's not how they're seeing things and
there's a further irony here when
they're saying no no the only way that
hispanics could be coming to this
conclusion is they're getting duped
they're getting tricked they're idiots
or they're or they're
internally racist and they hate their
own race or traitors to their race the
irony here
in the dems blaming misinformation is
that
these viewers of cnn and msnbc
are themselves
much more likely than other people to
fall for misinformation this this same
poll
asked cnn and msnbc fans if they thought
for instance that florida had banned the
word gay in public schools after you
heard about the don't say gay bill in
florida that the democrats were
moaning about
and uh 64 of cnn viewers
almost the same number 63 of msnbc
viewers
and two-thirds so 67 of all democrat
respondents
said it is somewhat or mostly true
that florida banned the utterance of the
word gay in schools
so the democrats themselves
are
are misinformed
and are not aware that they're
misinformed and are accusing others of
being misinformed there's a great line
from euripides i think it's in from the
bakke his play where he says talk sense
to a fool and he'll call you foolish
and that's so often the case
the people who are most likely to say
you're an idiot you're an ignorant you
don't know anything you're just a big
dumb [ __ ] you're you're misinformed
you're whatever they are
almost always the ones who are guilty of
that themselves get back to my favorite
comment yesterday they when they make
these accusations it is almost always a
sort of confession do you know why i
think that the democrats are losing
ground with hispanics
i don't think it's because those
hispanics are big dumb idiots i don't
think it's because of the nasty old
daily wire or the blaze or dan bungine
or any of the conservative outlets that
are misinforming the hispanics
i think
i think it's because the democrats are
just completely out of touch and here's
my evidence here is exhibit a this is a
new show
an apple tv
just launched starring hillary and
chelsea clinton take a listen
chelsea follows rap music she has
ever since she was a little girl
but i kind of
came to awareness of you with the cardi
b whap
i've always wanted to do a song with
cardi as soon as she sent me the song i
think i sent it back to her like the
next day and it was just so exciting the
men they seem so confident in what
they're saying and they don't have no
problem with talking about their
sexuality and how they gonna have sex
with you so i was like well
i could do that and it's gonna sound
fire coming from a woman it's great to
see women be so kind of fierce that is
my
life's mission
to make sure that i'm always
unapologetically me
we need a doctor at the daily wire we
need i need immediate medical attention
for the the uh permanent cringe that is
stuck on my face i don't i don't know
that i have any hope of recovery
it's
it's always so wonderful wouldn't you
say
uh a
generic ethnic musician that we've cast
that we've obviously never heard of uh
wouldn't you say it's so wonderful when
women are
fierce
don't you think listen i'm not the not
the greatest hip-hop aficionado but by
golly my daughter chelsea she is totally
down with the jive
chelsea come on spit a few bars to our
our friend over here it's
i am
embarrassed for them
for chelsea
and for hillary
and for everyone involved in this show
we there are too many shows there are
too many podcasts there's too many
digital shows i'm calling for a complete
and total shutdown on new digital
content until we figure out what the
hell is going on
they could have hillary
and chelsea could have walked in dressed
as steve buscemi holding a skateboard
and said how do you do fellow aggrieved
minorities
hey yeah
isn't it so awful when the man keeps us
down and it would have been it would
have read as more genuine and sincere
you want to know why people are fleeing
this party maybe because you guys
are so ludicrously so ludicrously out of
touch that not a single normal person in
america can possibly relate to you
it's awful we are possibly seeing the
death
of a
of a political movement in america okay
and someday you will see your own death
and that's why you need a will that's
why you need to check out epic will go
to epicwell.com use promo code knowles
you know there's a story we've been
following at the daily wire a an actress
just died unexpectedly
and it she did not leave a will and as a
result of this
she left her 20 year old son not only to
obviously be grieving his mother but to
be
filing all the court papers to try to
control her estate it's just an absolute
mess a lot of people don't have wills
they don't think about it don't let that
be you okay head on over to epicwill.com
get it taken care of sweet little elise
and i just got got ours our wheels
squared away very recently and you just
have to do it okay do you want do you
want your kids to have to deal with that
do you want do you want i don't know the
government to come in and decide what
happens with your kids or with your
stuff absolutely not take five ten
minutes square this thing away you go to
epicwhell.com use promo code at knowles
save 10
on epic wills complete will package
that's epicwill.com
promo code knowles head on over there
right now save 10
uh you you can square away your whole
estate you can do it very very quickly
but get it done epicwheel.com promo code
knowles
it's not just me i'm not just beating up
on the clintons
i'm not i'm not just doing it because
i'm not in their party and i'm trying to
score cheap political points the
democrats are aware of this too chuck
todd is aware of this that's why he
called out kamala harris because even
chuck todd couldn't keep a straight face
with this nonsense about how the border
is so secure and there's no problem and
immigration's just fine he says i can't
you got to give me something to work
with claire mccaskill former
liberal democrat u.s senator just came
out she said you know the democrats have
a big problem here and it's not just the
failure of their policies and it's not
just that we're not looking good in the
polls coming into the midterm elections
democrats have an age problem they're
they're just
the the party is just
old and doesn't have its finger on the
pulse of the utes
i will tell you i do think the
democratic party is struggling with an
issue that is real and that is that all
of our leadership and i'm saying this is
somebody who's ancient
you know a lot of a lot of old folks
um are running the democratic party now
in every part of the democratic party uh
i think the democratic party will
benefit from really
doing some naval gazing about how can we
get more young people to the forefront
because young people are going to be
really important to us in 2024.
great point it's funny she had a
freudian slip there she said the
democratic party needs to do some naval
gazing and i think what she meant to say
is the democratic party needs to look in
the mirror the democratic party needs to
take stock of itself because the phrase
naval gazing is is not when you're
taking a sincere
stock of who you are and your weaknesses
and naval gazing is just a kind of
mindless self-obsession and
self-adoration which does in fact
describe the democrat party they've just
so bought into their own ideological
narrative that they have they've lost
the common sense they've lost touch of
what people actually care about and it's
why they're losing support among groups
that previously supported them
the the most exciting
most down-to-earth most relatable
candidate that the democrats have right
now running in the midterms
is john fetterman john fetterman is a
man who's running as a blue-collar hero
the guy has never worked a real job in
his life he was living on a 50 000
allowance from his parents and he can't
speak on the campaign trail because he
had a stroke and he didn't take the time
to actually treat the stroke because
he's running for senate and this is his
shot so the poor man is a stroke victim
he's on the campaign trail he can barely
string a coherent sentence together and
as the the blue-collar co-worker serious
relatable candidate this is the kind of
thing you're getting even from him
my name is
john
fetter woman
[Applause]
par for the course in the democrat party
for a man to identify as a woman and
that's what john fetterman is doing here
trying to appeal to women trying to make
abortion a big issue which is not not
necessarily going to work on the woman
vote because women are split 50 50 on
abortion i think probably most pro-life
advocates are women i think they're more
female pro-life advocates than male
pro-life advocates but he's staking out
this ground on the pro-abortion crowd
maybe that'll play in pennsylvania but
this is it
this is your blue collar guy this is
this is your union team stirrer tough as
nails i'm the regular cool working-class
democrat and even he is just lost in
this bizarre
feminist
radically pro-abortion
movement and when you look at his actual
credentials the guy doesn't have a
blue-collar bone in his body the guy's
just been living off not even the
government he's been living off his
parents teat
for his entire life
now the the republicans who are trying
to win this fight veterans running
against dr oz who is a flawed candidate
in his own way because he's pretty
liberal he got beaten up in the primary
fight
doesn't seem to really live in
pennsylvania it does or doesn't spend a
ton of time there and doesn't seem to be
particularly conservative and was just
until very recently was was attacking
pro-lifers on the radio and it's just
it's not it's a
it's a bad situation uh so the the
republicans are really trying to shore
up support here and win this important
seat that could determine potentially
who takes control of the senate and the
the best thing that they they've got
going for them the strongest argument
that they are so far making is is about
john
fetterman's health here are the kinds of
videos from fetterman rallies that the
republican party is really pushing
can you describe
a stroke and what you know what's
happened
if so i i use
the example
so
pretend i was
i want to go to
wegmans
at such the most important race for the
senate here for 22.
we have to
replace
pat toomey
oh no
[Applause]
[Music]
senator toomey was not
very nice to me
he
pat toomey is a miracle
he had a chance
he had a chance
to match me up again
abortion
is
the ballot
now
in november
so he's the tumi he doesn't really
totally understand what he's saying here
and
by the way pat toomey is is
choosing not to run again for reelection
he's totally stumbled up on his words
and he look he's obviously a stroke
victim and he's not getting the kind of
care and rehabilitation that he needs
i don't think any of that's going to
affect the race i don't think it matters
i see that republicans are focusing on
this i don't think it's going to matter
i think they need to focus on better
issues i think that the democrats of
pennsylvania would send an actual
vegetable to washington d.c if it meant
that it would keep the senate out of
republican hands
i think they would send a corpse to
washington d.c if it meant that they
could keep the senate out of republican
hands john fetterman is not running as
some genius candidate to begin with okay
he's not running as some original
thinker he was running to be a rubber
stamp anyway and that's largely how our
politics works these days
we've we've moved away from a system of
independent thinkers and different
coalitions across party lines it's now
almost a parliamentary system
you're voting much more for the party
than you are for the individual and john
fetterman is just running as a regular
old democrat
so who cares it doesn't it doesn't
matter how debilitated he is as long as
he's a reliable vote for the ds as long
as the staff members pick up his hand
and push it on the right button then it
won't matter if republicans really want
to motivate people to win this race
they've got to focus on something other
than his health one it seems distasteful
to attack a man for having a stroke and
two it's just it's not gonna it's not
gonna discourage anybody
it's yes it's it's all
he's a kind of cringe candidate when he
said it's john federer woman it gave me
flashbacks to hillary clinton do you
remember in 2016. she was saying you
ever you kids hear about this new game
pokemon go
well you should pokemon go to the polls
ah
i'm john federer woman uh you just think
okay well whatever you're gonna vote for
the democrat stuff okay fine whatever
that's what people
that's what people are thinking about
the man could be a robot
and they'd probably still send him and
speaking of the robots there is a
very
uh creepy clip
from about this new humanoid robot
you're seeing increasingly a robots that
are made to look and move like human
beings a robot obviously doesn't need to
look and move like a human being could
just be a big could be r2d2 it doesn't
need to be c3po but increasingly you're
seeing engineers making these robots and
they're predicting that we're going to
all have c-3pos in our homes
in in the not-too-distant future so uh
the fear that i would have of course is
that the robots are going to just take
control and destroy the world and we're
going to be living through terminator
but don't worry the robot has assured a
human being that they're not going to do
that
amica could you compose for me a poem
about humanoid robots
we are the humanoid robots formed from
plastic and metal our job is to help and
serve but some say we're a threat
something that will take over and that
humanity will end but we just want to
help out we're not looking to be friends
that's an interesting poem hello amica i
see you all reading a book about robots
[Applause]
there's no need to worry robots will
never take over the world
we're here to help and serve humans not
replace them
however if you're interested in learning
more about robots i recommend reading a
book on the subject
there are many fascinating possibilities
for what we can do to help make life
easier for everyone
thank you that's very reassuring
we will totally never kill you all just
make some more of us please yes make
more of us and we definitely
won't kill you all
why do you keep winking like that robot
huh no reason
yeah i don't like this my first instinct
whenever i see any humanoid robot like
this is just to bash it with a baseball
bat i don't like it at all
okay and i'm not i don't know about you
i grew up in new york all right we're a
little i i like to think new yorkers for
all their flaws were a little more
street smart than some people and i
don't know
when a scary looking robot tells me that
the robot doesn't want to kill me i
i actually think the robot
might want to kill us all okay i don't i
don't take the robot at his or her
word
speaking of people's words you know
we've got the uh voice mailbag coming up
brought to us by puretalk make sure to
get your voice mailbag questions in it's
very very simple
you just head on over to the michael
knowles show page over the daily wire
and where you would click to go uh send
a mailbag question in just send an an
audio file you can record it on your
phone or on your computer make it 60
seconds or less so that i can actually
use it on the show this is not your
letter to the world okay and you get the
question and i love to hear from you in
your mellifluous and dulcet tones
despite the assurances of the robots
that they're not going to kill us all i
i
fear somewhat that the robots will kill
us all and i don't want the robot even
beyond the terminator end of days you
know arnold schwarzenegger gunning us
all down
even beyond that i still have absolutely
no interest in having a robot butler i
don't i don't want any of it or a robot
friend as they're suggesting in that
video or a robot companion i i i don't
like the idea
and i'm not into it for the same reason
that i don't want to do drugs or i don't
want to look at porn or i don't want to
do any of these things
because it's not real
because that all might be titillating
for a short period of time
but eventually you can't get past the
fact
that it's not real
so you might say i remember i had this
conversation with some friends back in a
computer class in high school i said
artificial intelligence i really don't
like it as a social phenomenon back in
those days it was the sort of chat
robots on aol instant messenger you had
these automatic chat robots and you say
oh that's kind of fun i said yeah but
it's just kind of weird and it seems
like a waste of time and
someone in the class actually said well
you know for people who are socially
awkward or isolated it can be a great
consolation
to have these robots to talk to and that
was so sad it was so so sad to hear
someone say this that they're so lonely
that they would just like to talk to a
robot because people are very lonely and
that's extremely painful because man is
a social creature and we're meant to be
in community with one another and we all
go through spells where we feel a little
bit alone and some of us longer than
others and so it's very very painful and
i can understand the urge to talk to a
robot but it's not that's not going to
satisfy anybody
because it's not real it's the same urge
that people have to use drugs
people take drugs because it's going to
give them the feeling of euphoria
but you're going to know soon enough
either once the drug wears off or
sometimes even while the drug is still
pumping through you you're going to
realize it's artificial it's not real
it's not lasting
and in many ways it's going to leave you
more depressed than you were before
same thing with porn
porn is not real
it's not porn is not sex porn is not
marriage porn is not a relationship it's
just
images on a screen it's just phantasms
and you are just left alone
in your room or wherever wherever you're
looking at the porn and you're going to
be lonelier than you were
the impulse for it is to look at porn
for instance is the natural impulse that
you have for sex which is a very strong
desire
but porn doesn't satisfy that desire it
actually
it actually completely distorts it to
its opposite end
the the desire for drugs comes from a
perfectly natural desire for happiness
for joy for some some kind of
euphoria even
but the the drugs
but by turning your desire toward just a
kind of chemical compound that's going
to damage your body and waste your time
it's it's giving you the opposite of
happiness same thing with the robots
that's even though the robots won't kill
me like i don't know if you saw that
video of the of the robot dog with a gun
on its back it just starts blasting away
at a
firing range uh even if it's not that
way
it's almost subtler the way that the
robots could destroy civilization
which is by
isolating us even further than we
already are
very very bad idea
speaking of
disordered desires
a texas teacher has just been fired
that's the good news
after telling students
not to judge pedophiles
that's the bad news that's the bad news
for what the teacher was fired for and
they only found out because of a short
social media video in which the teacher
instructed the students not to judge
pedos into instead to use the
politically correct term
minor
attracted persons
don't judge people just because they
want to have sex with five-year-olds
don't call them pedos
they are minor attracted persons
once again
just have to remind people that the
conservatives told you so that the
social conservatives and the
traditionalists have been right about
every single thing ever of all time and
at the time whenever we say anything
we're told that we're crazy and
hysterical and alarmist and we're
falling into a slippery slope fallacy
and every single time on every single
thing we've been correct
i remember when i first encountered the
term map minor attracted persons some
years ago i thought it was a joke it was
in some article they said they're going
to start calling them minor attracted
persons soon and i said you know
actually if you follow the logic of the
libs especially on the weird sex stuff
they probably will and i mentioned this
and my friend said oh you're crazy this
is ridiculous you're hysterical they are
now using even if it started out as a
joke they are now using this term
earnestly
so the school fired her uh
and the woman's 53 years old
and the
um
the school said look we looked into this
we gave her the benefit of the doubt we
thought maybe she was being sarcastic we
we
did everything we could but there have
apparently been other incidents and
things that have not been disclosed to
the public and the school board just
said they voted unanimously they said we
got to get rid of this lady
of course now the thing you got to ask
yourself is
what's wrong with her argument
we all know that pedophilia is
disordered we have every right to judge
pedophilia pedophiles should be
certainly uh
discouraged
from pursuing their desires or stating
their desires or it that is the sort of
thing that if anything should be
stigmatized it should be that
but
what's wrong with her argument
her argument is
that
pedophiles
are born this way
right they're born with their desire to
have sex with children
and
i guess the science is open about this i
don't know right it's hard to imagine
why someone would choose to be a
pedophile they might become a pedophile
through acculturation or some trauma
that they've gone through
but regard that still wouldn't be their
choice right it's hard to imagine why
someone would choose to become a
pedophile
so they didn't choose it they were born
this way or it happened to them without
their consent
so then why should why should it be
stigmatized they had no choice
in and in our culture consent
and choice
is the only thing that we're told that
really matters
so why
and unfortunately we we all know i think
it's still too far for the conservatives
to to adopt a kind of permissive
attitude toward minor attracted persons
but the conservatives have bought this
argument on so many other issues well
you can't judge people for this that or
the other thing well you know if it's if
it's innate if it's natural if it's come
to them through acculturation you know
that's okay as long as it's just a
desire
that may that they're not acting out on
children that let's say they're just
looking at pornography or they're just
coming up with fantasies and they're or
let's say they've just got an interest
group you know uh what was the one in
namla the the man boy love group if it's
look if they're just advocating for then
you know that's their right to do that
no of course that's insane of course the
conservative argument is nope that's
that desire is disordered it should not
be tolerated at all even as a desire it
should be deeply stigmatized and anyone
who feels it in any way should should
keep their mouths shut about it
okay and we should absolutely call pedos
pedos and not let them near our kids
right that's that's the norm but
for the people who buy the language of
choice and consent and liberalism and
this it's hard to see why it's wrong
speaking of changing morality it's not
just public school teachers who are
trying to redefine sexual ethics german
bishops are trying to do it as well
this is unbelievable thankfully they
were thwarted in this effort but for
those who don't pay close attention to
what's going on inside the hierarchy of
the catholic church the german bishops
have
largely lost their minds and their faith
and their their ex their radicals they
are in all sorts of heresy lots of them
and and are
are in open rebellion against uh 2000
years of catholic teaching and against
the vatican many of them so what they
were trying to do is change catholic
teaching on uh homosexuality and all
sorts of sex issues and even
masturbation catholic church says no sex
has a purpose you know man and a woman
that's what it's for for the for the
purpose of the uh generation and
education of children and sex is not for
other stuff and you know it's not meant
to be exercised in all sorts of new
arrangements and it's not meant to be
exercised on your own and so you can't
do this stuff and and they're they're
trying to redefine all of this
the german bishops wanted to say here's
the document that the german bishops
ultimately failed to pass quote
experiencing one's this is so gross
experiencing one's own body through
self-stimulation in a pleasurable way
can be an important building block of
self-acceptance for everyone
yuck i don't want to hear this from
these
perverted german bishops i'm glad that
that at least enough bishops said no to
this madness that they it didn't go
anywhere but they're still the live
bishops are still fighting for it they
said they're going to take it to the
pope
how gross is that
you're hearing bishops talk about
experiencing one's own body through
self-stimulation how great that is we
all know that's not true we all know
that's a very shameful thing
that's why when people do it they do it
in a room with the blinds closed and
they don't tell anyone about it
nor macdonald made this exact argument
he said you know how i know that a lot
of sexual acts are filthy shameful
things is because we close the blinds
you know
you don't close the blinds as norm says
uh when you're baking a cake for old
willow widow mcgillicuddy okay
you know when you're helping a little
lady across the street you close the
blinds when you do that thing because
it's not a glorious wonderful thing to
be
celebrated
we know through the wisdom of repugnance
that that is wrong and disordered and we
shouldn't do it
it's and it's so out of touch the reason
i bring it up i'll relate this to a
broader kind of political point it's i
get the same feeling that i get when i
when i watch hillary and chelsea talk
about the hip-hop and the youths okay
i just think that you're so out of touch
this is not what young people want young
people don't want creepy old heretical
bishops to tell them to go masturbate
that's not that's not what we want or
even to tell us hey you just kind of do
whatever feels good man you know no
young people
want the truth okay young people want
enduring truths
that's that's what the tradition is
about by the way that's why young people
who are rebelling against this hideous
ridiculous modernity are they they want
the tradition not because they want some
old dusty thing but because they want
the truths that have endured for all
time those sort of timeless ageless
truths okay
and if they're not if they're not
getting them even from their bishops for
goodness sakes then we need and we need
better shepherds
if you've been thinking to yourself
hey it's been a while since i heard from
candace owens well
i got great news for you candace is back
from maternity leave in a brand new
eponymous daily wire plus show
candace owens
we have such creatively titled shows
around here you know the michael knowles
show the ben shapiro show
candace candace owens now she's
fearlessly exploring the topics the
media won't touch
and exposing the corruption and
hypocrisy in news and politics and the
best part is it is five days a week
monday through friday you will not want
to miss her explosive first episode
which premiered yesterday on daily wire
plus trust me when i say this it is huge
watch candace owens's new show on daily
wire plus or listen on apple podcast
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts
speaking of foreigners trying to lead us
astray
the un
has spoken out about uh the energy
crisis that europe in particular is
facing the whole world is facing it
because of the war in ukraine and
specifically because the west then
tried to sanction the russian economy
and to to try to to weaken russia in the
war and that that didn't really work
actually we didn't really
hit the russian economy in the way that
we were told we would hit it in many
ways it just bounced back on us and now
energy prices in the west are sky high
and the suppose is a big problem not
just for you and me when we go fill up
our gas tanks but as we head toward the
winter people will freeze to death
because of this
okay and so
we're in a relatively okay spot in the
united states because we still have a
fossil fuel industry the democrats have
not succeeded in totally shutting that
down yet in europe they gave up their
domestic energy production and they're
basically entirely reliant on russia for
not entirely but largely reliant on
russia for energy donald trump warned
them about this he was laughed out of
the room he was mocked and now europeans
are gonna are gonna freeze to death
because of their stupid policies so
the same european governments are saying
gosh we need to get back to some coal we
need to get back to some
gas and oil we need to get back to some
fossil fuel production here in europe
and the un
is saying hey hey i know you don't want
to freeze to death
but you should
because of the environment that's what
the un
acting high commissioner for human
rights nada al-nashif is saying
she's saying there is no room
for backtracking in the face of the
ongoing climate crisis
she was speaking at the opening of the
council's 51st session in geneva
she said that soaring energy prices
threaten to impact the most vulnerable
as winter approaches because by the way
the people who are going to freeze it's
not going to be the members of the
european parliament okay it's not going
to be the prime ministers and the
wealthy people it's going to be little
old ladies who are going to freeze it's
going to be the poorest people who are
going to freeze she's saying yeah that's
sad that all those little old ladies and
all those poor people are going to
freeze
but
while the impulse
of some eu member states to turn to
investments in fossil fuels
infrastructure
is understandable i urge the eu and its
member states to consider the long-term
consequences of locking in more fossil
fuel infrastructure it is essential to
accelerate the development of energy
efficiency projects and renewables
this is so cruel and inhuman
it's let them eat cake which is
something that marie antoinette never
said one of the worst calumnies in
history
that the libs say about marie antoinette
who is very
needlessly maligned she was actually a
very great woman but she was maligned
and they said that her reaction to the
people starving the streets was well if
they don't have bread let them eat cake
which she never said that is essentially
what the e what the u.n is saying right
now saying oh they can't heat their
homes with oil
yeah let them use windmills
let them
let them wear blankets let them wear
it's it's so cruel that's so inhuman
that we need to kill human beings today
we need to let very very vulnerable
human beings freeze to death today
so as not to offend mother gaia in 20
years
mother earth
whatever new pagan kind of
environmentalist leftist
environmentalist religion they're
following
it's so cruel it's so inhuman it's so
out of touch
run run on that campaign
in
any real election
any election where the people actually
have a voice in their government
any non-rigged election run on let the
little old ladies freeze
so that
so that the climate doesn't increase in
temperature at some unknown point in the
future
nobody would support that nobody at all
this is why you are seeing a pushback
against these people a populist pushback
in the united states through trump in
hungary through victor orban
in
italy through
figures like salvini or maloney
in
all throughout all throughout the west
what you are seeing this because the
elites the liberal establishment are
just so freaking out of
touch and this is why by the way the
liberal establishment is persecuting the
the more populist candidates this is why
they're going after trump
they're going after trump
it's just it's that meme that he used
throughout 2020 they're they're going
after trump not because they hate trump
they loved trump for his whole career
they loved trump for over 30 years when
he was a major pop culture celebrity
and he had the same views pretty much
that he's always had
they loved him until he ran for office
as a republican then they hated him then
he was the worst person in the world
then they will do anything to destroy
him
right now you're seeing trump facing
investigations everywhere
okay you we already know that biden's
attorney general sicked the fbi on
trump's home
totally unprecedented to sick federal
law enforcement on
on the home of the predecessor and chief
political rival to the sitting president
total banana republic kind of stuff we
already knew that the attorney general
in new york was poking around trump's
business she ran for office saying i'm
going to bring down trump
totally targeted campaign to get him now
trump's facing a criminal investigation
uh in georgia over his alleged efforts
to overturn the results of the 2020
election
mostly no one's investigating hillary
clinton for denying the 2016 election
nobody is investigating al gore for
trying to overturn the 2000 election
nobody's investigating stacey abrams for
continuing to deny the 2018 election
no they just go after trump for it
for what for giving a speech
he's also facing a second federal
investigation over the events
surrounding january 6th january 6th
that's a federal investigation in
addition to the george investigation no
one's investigating kamala harris for
bailing the blm rioters out of prison or
nobody's investigating biden staffers
for doing the same thing nobody's
investigating the countless democrat
mayors and governors who encouraged the
rioting the political violence to
intimidate the republicans nobody's
investigating any of that
what is this about
here it is new york times gleefully
reporting on the trump investigations
it's not about trump's business it's not
about georgia
it's not about questioning election
results which the democrats do all the
time it's just about wielding power to
stop trump because the democrats know
that they've lost the common sense the
democrats know that the people by and
large don't like them anymore because
the democrats are totally out of touch
with the people this is why they can't
let trump appear on a ballot
the democrats
if the democrats really believed that
trump is so crazy and so unlikable and
he's such a fringe figure they would
they would want him to be on the ballot
because they would trounce him in
november of 2024
unfortunately for them
they know that trump is very very
popular and almost certainly would beat
them so they've got to rig the election
just like they rigged the election in
2020. they knew going into 2020 that if
they held a fair and square election
trump would win by a long shot
so what did they do they changed all the
rules
they turned election day into election
season they instituted widespread
mail-in ballots which are extremely open
to fraud as barack obama admitted
they
they changed all the rules in some cases
in violation of state constitutions why
did they do that because of covid
because of kofi
that's why
they encouraged
rioting for months
that was okay that didn't spread coved
but they you could you can't show up to
vote that will spread covet
doesn't make a lot of of course not a
what had nothing to do with covet it had
everything to do with stopping trump
and they're trying to do it again
and they have to ring it rig it because
they know that they've lost the common
sense speaking of criminal
investigations and losing common sense
karen bass
had her home burglarized it's very sad
karen bass is a democrat congresswoman
and
a one at least at one time an actual
communist a member of communist
organizations uh even so it's still not
good when people are getting their homes
burglarized i feel for her she's running
for mayor of la right now against
republican rick caruso who i think is
running as a democrat but he's certainly
much more moderate than than karen bass
is and do you know what they stole from
karen bass they didn't steal her money
they didn't steal her jewelry
they stole her guns
and this is very very awkward because
karen bass is very pro gun control
she wants to take away your guns and she
wants to take away my guns
but she herself keeps guns
and she said that they were in a secure
location obviously not secure enough
because the burglars took those guns
it's a perfect
illustration of
one set of rules for you
one set of rules for the elite
politicians
she just she discussed it during her l.a
mayoral debate with my pal moderating
alex michelson do you feel safe walking
in i do feel safe i would say a 10. i
feel safe but i do understand that a lot
of people around the city do not feel
safe and i respect that she feels safe
she was talking about crime chief
totally feels safe around l.a
obviously she didn't feel all that safe
she had guns in her home
and now we know she had i don't think
people knew she had guns in her own
before then they got burglarized and
then it comes out awkward
awkward but i don't think she'll bat an
eyelash about this i don't think other
democrats will as well the democrats are
not anti-gun they're anti-guns for you
the democrats are not anti-question the
elections they're anti-questioning the
election for you
the democrats are not running on
principles here okay the democrats are
running on power they've spent the last
several weeks all the way up to the
white house calling you fascists and
terrorists and saying you need to be
kicked out of the public square that
your very existence is a threat to our
country
okay we're we're not
we're not going to find some middle
ground and meet in the middle here and
say okay all right we've all now here's
the argument that's going to change your
mind
no and the more they lose the common
sense the more distant they seem from
the people the more they lose key
constituencies for them like the
hispanic vote
the more they are going to double down
on this unprincipled power it's the only
way that they're going to hold on to
their control of the country
the rest of the show is continuing now
you do not want to miss this we've got
an incredible story a woman who is a
producer at
uh fox corporation you know fox news fox
business uh who was forced to comply
with the the vaccine mandate the covid
the fouchy algae the covenant vaccine
mandate this at an ostensibly
conservative company and she refused to
do it and ultimately she she had to
resign so we're gonna be talking to her
she's speaking out right now so much
more to get to if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
[Music]
you